un événement très commentée dans la
presse c'est la fille de kylie jenner et
travis wood qui a fêté ses deux ans vous
connaissez kylie jenner et travis moen
et rien de choco pour ces deux ans
puisque l'après midi la famille a passé
la passer dans un parc d'attractions qui
commence par dix ce qui finit par
nescafé parler c'est la soirée
puisqu'ils ont créé un énorme parc
d'attractions à l'effigié de la petite
stormy qu'elle s'appelle storni baptisé
store new world
c'est à dire qu'ils ont fait une pour
ces deux ans mais fait là deux ans à
comprend rien mais finalement on l'a
d'or mais mon frère m'a ne va pas s'en
souvenir et ils ont créé un parc
d'attractions d'attraction vous avez une
compil des trucs les plus ouvre regarder
[Musique]
voilà bordeaux signe en mairie
oh
non
[Musique]
alors la soirée d'anniversaire
l'app store ni deux ans a coûté 100
mille dollars j'avais dit à mes
anniversaires comme ça avoue banon
chaque année bien sûr il faut faire quoi
t'es pas la tour eiffel à la tour eiffel
tout à fait l'appel tant à faire quoi
elle tend vers bahreïn pour manille un
slam à une dernière fois bas rien je le
sens bien mais jamais pourquoi ils n'ont
pas eu ça parce que là les parents ils
essayent de satisfaire leur mégalomanie
et passe donc voilà pourquoi ils ont pas
ce genre d'animaux la célèbre chant des
mâles ras le cul de cette société de
consommation à l'entente passée pour le
vieux cons en phase i d'une indécence
total ces histoires dans le l'enfant vit
d'amendé un enfant lui offrait pas
qu'est ce qui amuse le plus c'est
l'emballage la faire un truc comme ça
c'est pour étaler son esprit créé si je
me permets tu as qui font du mal à
personne
ils font ce qu'ils veulent de leur fric
sale ça descend mexique le panama ça
s'appelle un travail c'est leur travail
ils montent sur la scène leur life s'est
révélé gérant les gens qui kiffent
savait plus large et le rôle dans tout
ce qu'ils veulent dans la production ça
me la mets au kenya raisons
effectivement c'est la marque de
fabrique des kardashian elle se vendent
et elles vendent aussi leur enfant entre
guillemets donc l'exubérance et de
s'exprimer at a raison de dire avec les
hells ont fait l a fait kim kardashian
fait une malheureuse sextape
c'est tout l'enjeu n'était pas à les
séparer ce que tu as à bien les faire ce
que tu es que toi aussi tu règles à
temps mais c'est pas parce que toi mais
région dach marc tu vas devenir
militaire examinait mais voilà elles
vendent une marque en l'occurrence
l'heure elles sont elles mêmes leur
propre marque donc il fait qu'elle
alimente mal vendent leurs enfants est
ce que moi j'ai exploité des enfants à
pacy
le dit oui mamie abonde indépendamment
du reste ça aussi ça fait vieille conne
mais ces gens là font toujours tout
semblant de sauver la planète et sa
énergétiquement cd gouffre ces machins
là et ça sert strictement à rien tant
que moi je trouve ça draine que des
valeurs négatives dans le parc barney
est ce que ça vous choque les enfants
moi ma chérie moi je normal 20 ans
balles normales
une fête comme ça pour ça les deux ans
de leur fille ou pas c'est trop bas ils
font ce qu'ils valent zaoui alors oui
c'est à dire qu'on approuve
c'est du grand n'importe quoi j'ai senti
l'énergie si je suis trop ils feront
quoi on va vous c'était il ya deux ans
la 18e à la télé ça t'énerve tout ça
ouais bah pour tuer la planète s'est
super bien passé tout le gâchis de
bouffe j'imagine oui mais voilà bah tu
vois toi bien tu es bien lutté bien le
digne fils de ma vie mais c'est rien oui
mais le truc c'est qu'ils font ils font
ça mais ils vont les utiliser qu'une
fois toutes ces places fixes et ses
visages c'est oui je sais pas après
c'est sûr c'est une marque comme je suis
pas oui qui disait mais c'est non moi je
trouve ça quand même le niveau
gaspillage comme commande ça te plaît
pas à quoi voilà c'est ça